welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm very excited to
finally be joined by ellie granny who is
the managing director of transition
partners
who are a tech recruitment consultancy
based in leeds
covering the uk and europe ellie has
progressed
from a trainee recruitment consultant
all the way up to
director level within this company in
just six years
ellie is currently responsible for a
team of four people
um and has really played a crucial role
in helping transition partners become
seen as a go-to technology recruitment
partner in
the north of england ellie thanks for
joining me hello
i feel like i'm so excited to finally be
here
you know we've been speaking a while
haven't we so um no no i feel like
you're my pen pal
like we've been speaking long distance
for ages
no yeah i'm definitely looking forward
to excited to dig into uh
your your journey so as i was saying
where i want to start
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think make up
a highly successful recruitment
consultant
oh god this is such a tricky question
and i feel like when i
interview potential recruitment
consultants transition partners that's
something that i think about all the
time what makes an ideal recruiter and
what should i be looking for
there isn't really one answer there's so
many things like resilience
positivity grit gravitas there's so many
different cocktails that make up a good
recruiter i think
um but for me there's that special
little spark
that you can find in someone that's able
to create a community
create a network and build connections
so maybe the sort of person you know
who can who on a tuesday night when no
one wants to go to the pub or go out for
a bit of a party and everyone says no at
first but they're the sort of person
that can create a hype
get everyone involved get everyone on
board and before you know you're having
a great night out
so like someone who can create something
really special
create meaningful relationships and get
everyone heading towards one vision
and i think that's something really
special that recruiters have got and i
think successful recruiters definitely
have that skill
interesting do you think that's
something that you had
at the beginning or do you think it's
something that can be taught i can
always get everyone a night out
yeah i think that's something that i've
always been able to do quite
successfully about like
bringing people together and creating a
bit of a vision and i think yeah that's
definitely played a key part in in
my success particularly at transition
partners every past six years
but do you think that can be taught
oh good question
oh 50 50 like maybe a little bit you can
like learn and you can watch other
people do it and see i mean like i
like i really feel like my job
recruitment isn't just recruitment
there's so many different aspects that
people don't
and and and i guess it's the different
aspects that make a really good
consultant
so bringing networks together
communities together training
supporting advising um
so many different aspects in that and
and as you get more experience you're
able to
to use those different skills and
utilize them on a daily basis
but i think some of it's intrinsic like
you've got to be a people person
there's so many people that go into
recruitment and i mean i've been at one
when you've been part of big psl and you
go to an agency briefing there's like
six other recruiters in the room
thinking
geez like they want to work with people
there's some people you think oh they're
not natural people people like
it's it's quite hard sometimes and you
think god how did they get into
recruitment but
i think you've got to love people you
love what you do you want to help people
advance and progress their career as
well
from from an agent my perspective
i don't just want to be placing people
in vacancies that's like
the obvious step i want to help them
achieve the next step and take a big
jump in their career so
that's what i love doing in recruitment
and um yeah i think hopefully if you've
got that little spark it can certainly
help
okay interesting so when preparing for
this i think you're
you you've accelerated your career quite
quickly for on on the face of it it
looks like that right
so it feels like a lot
a lot of early mornings and a lot of
late nights but yeah i guess so i guess
in comparison to
yeah because i was saying before real a
real common goal
whenever i've sort of um searched for
what people's
ultimate career goal is for their
recruitment career a lot of people
sort of lean towards wanting to sort of
head up their own team and grow their
own team or it's sort of
achieving that director status within
their agency
so why don't you start but like how how
would you describe your first year in
recruitment ellie
awful like the worst horrible year i've
probably ever had
it was tough like you cannot
underestimate like how tough that first
year
is and i mean my background i've never
worked in an office before so i was a
little bit like a caged animal like my
i didn't really want to go into
background and kind of before that i
worked in in the beauty industry and i
went in sales and
i traveled all over the world i met my
chap in in australia and he's from leeds
originally so
moved over here and i was um running a
champagne nail bar in harvey nichols in
in leeds so i was selling nail polish
yeah like i was selling
i loved it i had loads of vouchers for
now um for harvey nichols which is
amazing because i had a really good
handbag collection
but i didn't have any money for a
mortgage so i thought
you know what i'm gonna do something
different and a load of my clients
were recruiters and they were like
females doing
really well yeah and it was so cool to
see like these women come in and they
were sat there drinking champagne and
their nails done and i saw a really good
laugh with them
and they all said do you know what you
should get into recruitment
so i started at the very bottom i
interviewed with a few different
agencies in um
in leeds and through erector wreck and i
had no idea what i was doing to be
honest i didn't even i actually thought
the wreck direct was offering me a job
at first
i didn't know i didn't understand what
he was even doing so it was yeah
quite quite unusual circumstances
interviewed for a load of companies i
ended up getting quite a few offers
which was fantastic
and i went into recruitment at 24 so
for me it was like make or break this
isn't just an opportunity to give
something to go
it's either going to work or it's not
and if it doesn't work i'll be a bit of
a failure
so my first year i put a lot of pressure
on myself and sandra put a lot of
pressure on me which i loved in
hindsight
knowing the amount of accountability and
that she put on me
it was fantastic i worked with when i
first started the transition partners it
was just
sandra and emma who was still there i
wasn't gonna say why don't we
why don't you describe like what what
transition partners look like because i
think that can help with context on the
journey that you've been
but like just really quickly like why
did you why did you choose transition
partners and that environment because
that
surely must have felt really quite
daunting if you're joining two people
in an office then yeah yeah
oh my god it was so daunting it was so
scary back then
yeah so i had a couple of i think i
interviewed in two days i interviewed
five agencies i got four offers one of
the off
uh one the one i didn't get an offer
with they're basically their response
was
um this isn't the sort of office where
we wear navy suits
they said um there's not our lads don't
have football style haircuts i don't
understand for ages i think god what the
hell are they on about i'm a
24 year old woman like this got
absolutely nothing to do
and i think that translated as like they
they were looking for
probably people a little bit more
vanilla whereas i'm definitely like a
mint choc chip kind of girl do you know
what i mean
it's all about personality and making
relationships with people when
and and for me it definitely would have
never been right it was working in
accounting
recruitment actually financial
recruitment um
and then the four other offers i had i
liked they were actually
all bigger businesses apart from
transition partners which was the
smallest
so sandra had started the business like
two years before and she was
a really successful recruiter and for
about
10 years before that and she worked some
amazing brands really good clients
emma um helped resource all the roles so
it was just the two of them in us
in a small office um right in the center
of leeds
and for me i could just tell there was
like a bit of opportunity like there was
a bit of a spark
i love the fact that i'll be working
with like two other strong women
and it was relatable and they were doing
i mean even membership like sandra sat
there with a personnel earrings and i
thought oh
i like this i could have a bit of this
so i thought that was all that time
all that time ago but i remember just
thinking
tech was probably the out of all the
industry that i'd interviewed with which
were like fmcg
and and finance tech was probably the
one i knew least about
and that came as soon as i accepted the
offer it became pretty apparent actually
because i couldn't even like turn
computers on i had like no idea
yeah like honestly it was it was a hell
of a shock to the system but
um i think it was about the people and i
knew that i could just spot like an
opportunity
i knew that this company had a lot of
potential
and it had the groundings of a really
good business and i thought why not join
something where you're number three
rather than number
53 and be another recruiter fair enough
but
with that comes more accountability
potentially responsibility
those things which it seems like you've
grasped so i guess
what what was i always like asking this
like what what was the best piece of
advice sandra gave you remember gave you
in that first year do you think
oh bloody ham don't give up until the
rolls are filled
that was basically it really we were an
absolute
dream honestly i still think about it
now like we were an absolute dream team
i don't know how we did it how we worked
back then is very different to how we
work
now and i think that's been a lot large
part of our journey as as leaders
is because that we were all so committed
to transition partners but when i say
blood sweat and tears went into that
this business i am not lying like the
amount of graft that went in
used to get into the office we see the
empty office for half six quarter to
seven in the morning we didn't leave
until nine ten at night
i didn't have when i first started like
it's a really good example i didn't have
a
car parking space i just in literally
said it was quite expensive to have
parking in leeds
so just to get the train in and out and
then it got to the point where
i kept missing the last train and i'd
have to pay for taxis home and it
kept happening all the time and because
i was just working too late i didn't
keep an eye on the time
and then sandra was like right we're
going to get your car parking space
because just working too many hours so
we ended up getting hooked up with
parking that made things a little bit
easier but
um i got that pretty quickly probably
within about three months because it was
clearly the amount of hours we were
putting in
but it and it was brilliant to be a part
of
and it was really really hard work i
think my first gray hair probably came
in about three months into recruitment
but it was really good and like i
learned
so much in every role we feel every role
we got we failed
i can't conversion rate was impeccable
like we all
we all believed in everything we were
doing and we kind of just grew from
there
and at that point i i came on with the
idea of being a 360 consultant
my biggest skill coming into recruitment
was that i was good at sales so it was
good working with people but
we had so much work on i couldn't we
just had to do delivery so i was just
doing 180
um for a long time which was great it
was a blessing
and a curse i think but i learned a lot
and it was very candidate-led
like candidates were at the forefront of
everything i was doing i built a really
strong network and i built a real good
community around me
uh at the time i was specializing in
business analysts
so more technical business analysts but
doing bits and business change and
transformation as well
and which was like the perfect market
for me because they're all like in tech
these are the people people in tech so
they've been they've probably
had to call me and share their knowledge
and tell me about all their other
friends in tech
and yeah it was really good fun but cut
my teeth first year
a lot of hard work not a fun experience
plenty of times i came home and
crying and saying i was going to give up
actually i did that a lot i think
my first year
yeah i did i did yeah it was i think
yeah it's
tough it was um why didn't you quit
oh why didn't i quit probably because i
wanted to
prove everyone wrong underdog complete
underdog my
um i guess from a personal perspective
my background
i i dropped out of school at 16 to go
into beauty
so i had i
left school all my friends were really
successful they all lived in london were
doing really really well
in like fashion and fintech and and i
went traveling and i spent loads of time
working in the beauty industry which was
great fun and i learned a lot and
created some really good networking
skills but i didn't really have anything
to prove
anything to like show from it my brother
was extremely successful
um he'd been to university he's a retail
director of a company down in london my
dad
had a successful business and i kind of
just thought you know what i need to
prove them that i can do really well
even though i dropped out of school
because when i dropped top school to go
to beauty school everyone was like what
the hell is she doing
yeah yeah and i think um from that
perspective everybody
everyone had thought i'd made a huge
mistake when i said i was going
traveling what are you doing big mistake
don't do that
you're going to waste a couple of years
and waste a load of money and
um i wanted to prove that i could put
the skills and everything i learned
it into like really bring it to fruition
i guess and
and recruitment gave me an opportunity
to do that which is brilliant
just so just really quickly then just on
that and then it'd be good just to get
some context on sort of how long you
were just delivery then when you
transition to more 360 management et
cetera but
you hear this all the time right like
why so why was ellie
able to sort of put the shutters on and
block those opinions out because a lot
of people would have taken on those
opinions and
not went into beauty and didn't go
traveling right so why
why i don't know i don't know if you're
stubborn or you're like no
no i am going to do but like why was you
able to sort of
listen to yourself rather than listen to
other people because especially when it
comes from family and stuff
yeah i think so actually yeah i guess i
went i went against everything i was
told to do
but i just i don't know yeah maybe no
one can say
no to ellie i get to get my own way
quite a lot of time
yeah i i just knew that i wanted to do
things at a certain time and
and and actually for me that was the
right time for when i came into
recruitment at 24
i had some life skills i've been i've
been places i've
i've met people from all over the world
and when it when and that was so
important like i think there's so many
people in like you've seen recruitment
adverts now and it's like
must have at least a 2-1 and must be
this and
xyz it's just to be fair it's a load of
[ __ ] because if you can
work with people you can speak to people
that is more important than anything and
traveling for example was a great way of
me to be able to network and meet people
that that weren't in my
that put me out of my comfort zone i
guess i come from quite privileged
background grew up in cornwall and
probably a bit shouted and yeah i mean
for me it was a huge learning experience
and then when i brought that to
recruitment
and i'd lived all over the country by
the time i've gone to recruitment as
well
i'd knew places and i knew um i guess
it was weird when you travel when you
can talk to anyone about anything
if you're quite well traveled anyway
you've got common ground with people
so i think that's a really good way to
be able to communicate and build
relationships so
things like that have been really really
helpful it's not your traditional route
but for me
for me it worked really well and and i
think it's helped help to my success as
well but starting at 24 it meant
i didn't have time to piss around like i
was i was going into recruitment and i
was going to take it really seriously
which i did so let's just map this out
for people listening then so
just focused on 180 delivery just
because i'm assuming sandra
had the jobs and pulled in the vacancies
and then you had you'd filled them or
obviously emerald support and these
things right
yeah so like how long did you do just
that
piece and then how long did you then and
then when was it when you did sort of
more 360 and i'm more involved on
business development and
delivery and then when did you actually
start the leadership journey just
for context for me and people listening
and we'll dig into it
so i think when i was about
two months in a transition partners i
was literally learning the basics right
i was so bad on the computer even so i'm
trying to put me on a touch typing
course because i just
i hadn't worked on a computer before i
had no idea so i just i spent an hour
every lunch doing touch typing and now
i'm actually with it
but it actually was really helpful for
me and but
all the basics two months in and someone
told me that she's pregnant
right which i had a feeling that she was
a woman
a certain age i think she really she'd
probably want a baby soon at some point
i'm sure
and um so she yeah so she was pregnant
and now she was pregnant
and i was a bit like at first i was like
oh god
what does this mean for me and what's
the name of emma and the business
but actually it was a really good
opportunity because um
sandra went on maternity leave i had the
opportunity to start managing her
um clients and take on some of the key
accounts
me and emma did an absolute sterling job
of like
running the business and growing we grew
the business while sandra was off
which was incredible um and then
when sandra came back by that point i
was ready to do business development so
i must have been probably been about a
year and a half into recruitment but
even at that point i didn't really have
to do it which
that like i said it's a bit of a
blessing on the curse because i wish and
someone had been like right
as much as a cold desk sounds awful i
think for me it would have been quite
good because then i would
literally just have to hammer it whereas
i didn't have to do that
which means a lot of my connections have
been built after from like
long standing relationships
recommendations
when clients had moved on so they might
have been one of sandra's accounts
initially but then i made a connection
with a specific
hiring manager within that business and
then they've moved and brought me with
them
so it happened quite organically um
which means they were like real
relationships rather than i guess yeah
that makes sense
and then so okay so that okay so about a
year and a half here and that makes
sense and then yeah
if you really um put in the work on the
candidates and then
you took on some clients of sandra's
yeah great great platform then to grow
clients and accounts and so then really
quickly then i've got one question
around the candidate
piece when did you when did he then
transition into
um a manager when did that start
happening just for context
i think i'd i think i took an apprentice
on with probably
the nemat yeah probably about a year and
a half at that point i think i probably
took
my first apprentice and that was one
hell of a learning journey for me
actually out of recruitment that's been
there
as much as i am a people person it's
been
yeah one hour so we
but there are so many tech recruiters
out there right yeah
so two questions actually one
how important is it do you think now if
you're looking back
clearly you made it work but like how
important is it for
tech recruiters to understand the tech
that they recruit for
oh yeah i mean for me i'm
the best person at finding the people
that can do that but that doesn't mean
i'm technical and you're not asking me
if you want me to fill five uh java
developer roles for example you're not
asking me to write the code so i
personally don't think i need to know
how to do it some people are more
technical
and i think that's great for them like
it's everyone's got different
angles for me personally my strength
isn't in the technical piece
it's about finding the people and
selling opportunity and creating
opportunity for people so
not for me but for others i think it is
valuable
i think maybe um if you're more of an
introvert
your style is a little bit softer you're
which actually works
really well and in real tech
technical recruitment to developers
devops cloud etc
if you are more sort of like there's a
softer approach to recruitment a real
um skilled approach to that then then it
can be a really valuable asset
but for me personally yeah it's not it's
okay
and then the other one is just like
like where do you think most tech
recruiters do badly when sourcing tech
talent
where do you think most tech recruiters
go wrong i think people assume that
people are always looking for work and
they're not
like the biggest i think the most common
mistake
in everyone in recruitment and i think
actually it's it's not often a lot of
people's fault it's
it's the pressure that managers put
behind them he said people always assume
people are looking
and they're candidates already but
they're not they're people
and they might not be looking right now
but they're looking they might be
looking in a year they might look it in
a couple of years but if you're in it
for the long game which i am
and i was then it's about building them
relationships and when those people are
ready they'll always come back to you
so i think um yeah i think that's really
really really important piece what was
your question again i went up
off piste no no no the question was
you've answered it the question was like
where do you think most
tech recruiters go wrong or yeah
um do badly when sourcing tech talent
and you said yeah always assuming that
they're open to
to work yeah sorry yeah i think i think
i think that's always the case yeah and
they're not and the way you approach
people is the long game not the short
term so i'm not a transactional
recruiter
but my experience in my business has
been built on reputation so
i think that's really important to
remember so what was as you did this as
you sort of transitioned then and we'll
talk about ellie the the manager but
like what was your biggest
like you said that you obviously built
up a great platform that in hindsight
really helped but like
what was your biggest challenge with
client development early on because this
is an area that
is the most popular area that recruiters
want to develop in or become better at
or
think they're sort of weakest in so like
what was your biggest challenge early on
do you think
access i think gaining access to people
in tech but you know what we're in leeds
we are so lucky i mean i started
recruitment in leeds and
we also work across europe now and all
over the uk as well so
but in leeds we're really lucky we've
got something very special
around the north around this tech
community and it's really welcoming
and gaining access to that market was
really important and being welcomed in
and
that's something that i've been working
on for years um particularly with the
i'm really involved in sort of like
events vlogs podcast personal branding
perspective
um is is a big piece of my work
but um i think being gaining access to
that was invaluable and i did that at
quite an early stage i think i held my
first
event when i've probably been for
transition partners for about a year
maybe a year and a half and then they've
kind of catapulted from there we run
about 30 tech events a year and it just
means i get to meet everyone and anyone
and usually if i meet someone
usually i'm good at my job so they want
to work with me so
um okay so let's talk about this then
so biggest challenge access but what
really helped you overcome that and get
access was
ultimately being the person or being the
business that hosted the access
basically right so yeah yeah so like you
just said
ended up actually hosting your first
tech event in like a year or so in
so let's just talk about this for a
second i think what you guys do well is
is definitely the branding piece and
events is obviously a huge part of that
so i think from my perspective i think
it's very easy for recruiters to go out
events being
they've been done people don't right you
can't do enough for them i don't think
yeah fair so i love that you said that
but i think it'd be easy
because everyone always wants to know
what the next thing is is it podcast is
it
videos on linkedin or whatever right
everyone wants to know what the next
thing is
so i'm glad you said that but like if
i'm listening right now
and i'm someone that's like you know
what i've actually really recognized an
opportunity that i can
give access to my network or i can
create the place where people can access
each other blah blah blah
like where did you where did you go
wrong with these events early on
why did i go wrong with them
maybe vetting the people that you that
you have attend
depending on what you were trying to
create i i soon
to be honest i got my head around them
quite quickly
and i think if you're just there to
create money out of an event it's really
bloody obvious and everyone can see
through it
so don't go in it with that goal but go
into it with the idea that you've got to
create a community and bring people
together
because if you bring people together and
introduce people to people they'll
introduce you to other people
and it just you gain access to a market
the hidden market
so um i think
yeah don't go in with a business agenda
but equally
start thinking about how you can turn it
into opportunities rather than deals
so i was getting to the stage this year
has been it's turned everything on its
head
around the event space but yeah last
year year before
i was probably making about at least i
think it was last year
80 grand worth of my fees came from
people that i've
introduced to someone at november so i
tracked it
just over 80 grand so yeah i um i
basically would invite hiring managers
invite specialists within the field that
i knew they were hiring these people
might not be looking for work at a time
or this person might be hiring right now
but making introductions like that
so yeah and then that's just that's just
from a billing perspective but from a bd
perspective yeah the opportunities have
been kind of endless off the back of it
um you've got how is it client
development how does it help client
development
the relationships you can build with
people you're just
getting time with people with with these
professionals i mean everyone's busy
right and if you haven't
if you're not at work you want to be
spending time with family or friends
but finding something that's a
combination of of all of that so it's
something there
tech people really passionate about what
they do so they're talking about
something they love which is
awesome because they're so passionate
about it
talking about something they love
they're in a room full of people with
the same
i guess that we're all on the same
wavelength and we're mutually we're all
having a great time there's a few drinks
there we're doing some networking we're
learning about one another
we're creating a community we we've got
this
same purpose same goals and yeah that's
something
there's such a buzz about good events
like honestly it's it's the favorite
part of my
my job actually is is the events because
the high that you get following an event
you just don't get that sat in the
office banging on the phone but the
results are actually much better
okay so what i'm gonna ask you
yeah is you've got
you've got the attendee list right this
is when we can meet face to face now
hopefully we can do more of that but i i
definitely have a question around
if i'm listening right now like how what
would you say to me if i want to start
creating this in a virtual world because
you've probably gone through these
learnings recently
but just just a real quick question
because i i was definitely rubbish at
this at the beginning
like if you had the attendee list and
you're like right i really want to try
and speak to
this person this person this person this
person yeah
what would be like what would be for you
what would be the
like how would you approach that like
how would you approach that person like
what would be the opener or like what's
your like
go to advice for your team who's like
right ellie so i know these people want
to speak to them like what would your
advice be to try and start a
conversation with them at
this event oh don't go and try and go in
technical
i wouldn't do that i'd definitely go in
more personal about
i guess other events they've been to
have they traveled from farm
what's it like what what brought them to
the evening was it the topic was it the
speaker have they been to
an event before you know just like
really it's just
a chat it's not we we have this habit of
putting
people on pedestals and it's just
they're just normal people
how many times have you been in a
situation where you like get really
nervous and i i get it really bad
actually because for
quite a confident person i'm quite uh i
guess fake it till you make it kind of
girl
but um i get a massive warning sign
because i get a big rash across my chest
so even though i might act cool and i'm
all right i'm not all right i'm
panicking and i'm nervous that anxiety
is there and i still do get nervous
before meeting people
but um yeah don't put people on a
pedestal they're just normal people like
us or i might stalk people a bit before
they arrive at the event as well and
find out like their background who was
mutually connected
how they've come to the event or signed
up for the event
i'll do a bit of research but the amount
of time
i've spent before like over the years of
having events like researching people
thinking yeah do you know what this
is a real opportunity we've got here
tonight guys and then
they turn up and you just can't spark a
conversation with that person
or it's just not meant to be or they
might not talk too much on the first
event you're not entitled to chat with
everyone just because they've come to
your event
but if you put on a really great event
they're not gonna they're not gonna
forget about it hey they're gonna want
to attend again but b
we gain access the next day because we
either ring everyone or email them for
feedback so we can improve our events
for the future
so if they've missed an opportunity
which does happen you can't speak to
everyone and these events you're
normally running around like crazy
anyway
and i'll get in touch with them after
and find out how they found it and if
they'll be coming to another event which
our events have got 100 success rate of
people saying yes i'll be coming back
so that's really because that was the
name of the question around that like
how important is follow-up
but you just answered that yeah really
important
and actually yeah because a lot of the
time
oh god like for some examples like some
of the events we're doing at the moment
last last week we had a technical one
which was all around um
devops which i'm not particularly
technical but the feedback forms that
might then help shape
the next event for us these technical
people might tell us about what they
want to learn
the next time or next month and we can
create a meet up and we can create
community out there
today's event before i've come on here i
was literally rushing around because
i've
um hosted a lunch a free lunchtime
webinar to try and help people who are
out of work get back into work at the
moment so
it was just like an interactive workshop
me and a um
an exec coach who helps train
individuals with interviews and
and progressing their careers we work
together to create like an interactive
lunchtime session
to help unemployed people and and it
seems like that you've got to be able to
add value
longer term and it and it will pay off
for sure
and but the feedback forms are really
great because then they'll help us know
what we can do better
and give us something from your audience
exactly
so it's a final thing on these events
then
like if i'm listening right now i'm like
right i'm convinced need some
i need to i need to start an event right
but we can't like you said like for sure
yeah i definitely can't
do the typical sort of blueprint of life
right let's
let's identify a topic and all these
types of things let's rent a bar
let's get food let's have a few drinks
can't do that like
over this sort of last six eight months
where you've had to adapt to whatever
like what would your advice be to me to
take action on this or how how would how
do you think i should approach it if i'm
listening and i want to
start an event what would you say to me
ask your community
what they want to learn about what can
you facilitate like you are the
middleman right that's our job we are
middlemen it's uh and women and our job
to find out what people want to learn
about and how we can help set up that so
um facilitating that is really important
arshy network how many linkedin
connections have you got can't just drop
a message out and find out what people
could they haven't learned about before
what have you not seen in a networking
event that you'd want to see
what can we do as a business to help
provide a platform for you to learn and
help progress your career
um but just ask your community ask your
clients i'd definitely try and find a
speaker for your first one that's that
spoke at events before for sure like you
don't want someone whose first event is
you want someone who's done it
and something like that previously maybe
mitigate risk by creating a panel and
from a branding perspective then if you
have the opportunity to host that panel
then even better because like i'm
hosting a panel on thursday and it's all
about thriving through menopause
which is a subject that is not like
something i'm particularly well informed
about but i've got some amazing women in
tech
talking about her and it's all about how
employers can help support women
and families going through the menopause
and what we can do better
so um i think being able to host the
events and actually host the panel was
get you gain immediate access to a host
of people that you wouldn't normally be
able to speak to which is really cool
okay so yeah remember that yeah you
don't have to be the speaker
find the people that you know listen to
speak to your audience about identifying
the topic
and and then yeah even better if you can
host the panel discussion
you'll just again you're creating the
access you're creating the
the place so for years i didn't host the
events by the way for years i just sat
in the corner
and like really well
maybe not quite so much but i kind of
did i'd do a bit of an intro hand it
over to the guest speaker and then i'd
do a bit of a close at the end but
um they're not saying that's it that's a
lot of feedback that we get actually
from our events which was probably quite
valuable
and for your listeners is that is that a
lot of other tech events they go to
they're quite salesy and it's really
clear
quite often people will come to our
events and then at the end of the event
they'll go
so what do you guys do then and for me
that's like the best like oh so great
they didn't
i know like most probably most
recruitment agencies owners will be
fuming like
we've wasted money they don't know who
we are but for me that's good because
you don't know who we are
a you want to ask who we are which is
brilliant but b
we haven't been selling to you it's a
softly softly what do you guys do in
tech
and and then we're able to build longer
lasting relationships
that's really good okay love that if
you're listening right now hopefully
let's take some action and and get
bringing access right that that's
i think even i think even more so now
from what i can see people want that
people want community people want access
i think it's probably
more normal just to jump on a video call
and attend something
and so if you're not convinced by sort
of the tangent that we just went on here
together i think ellie's really
living proof that this can work right so
give it a go and and and
like if if you are stuck or really want
to advise on you'd be keen to help at
least a lot
anyone that's listening wants to take
action on this like do that for sure
um so let's just talk about them for the
rest of time let's just talk about
ellie the director right how did that
happen so the great thing about
recruitment right is
it's there's no way that ellie is
getting opportunities like becoming the
managing director of this recruitment
business
unless you're unless you're delivering
unless you're achieving certain outcomes
right um so let's talk about this how
was ellie's journey in terms of
performance billings what did that look
like over the years over the last couple
of years
yeah i mean it's been it's been a
journey isn't it
i've i've always been one of those
people someone sets me a goal i will
over achieve and i'll do everything i
can to do that so i was very accountable
even though i was given roles as a 180
initially
i ran it like it was my own business
probably
that might have been quite annoying for
something to start with
it's like this girl coming in but i
that was really important for me because
i guess i've got quite a bit of
entrepreneurial spirit in me and i and i
i wanted to run it like my own every
responsibility i took on i was
accountable
i'd be doing bits when i was meant to be
on annual leave i'd be taking calls
late night and i was working every
sunday afternoon from four o'clock till
six o'clock every sunday i used to work
to find candidates because i wanted to
come in on monday morning with stevie's
ready to go
and i mean that's a long time ago now
and i think the way that we have to work
has changed it was probably a bit okay
archaic and its approach but then but
things have changed and
i the proof i guess was in the pitting
my first year i
ended up i think it was about 140k which
was
good uh
340 about 340. on per yes
it's parallel recruitment i do a little
bit of contract but not very much
um that's an amazing achievement
yeah and last year this year obviously
it's the first year actually i was a bit
annoyed it's the first year that i've
not grown
each year there's been quite been growth
and and it's effective in terms of your
billings performance yeah
yeah it's always gone so let's talk
about this
yeah this is probably one of the most
common things where people ask me want
to ask questions like
ellie how have you gone from 140 150k
100k
to the next level of hitting 200k it's
300k plus right
so let me start with this let what this
one i know you said that
i know you said like you just make
things happen right and you
easily admit that like you're not the
best person that has the best process or
whatever but people always want me to
ask
what what what does ellie's day look
like the 300k plus billa
compared to the 140 150k villa
oh god that's such a good question isn't
it and yeah like i said before i think
one of my problems one of my biggest
things i've heard to work as a leader is
explaining the way that i do things
because i feel i find that really
challenging because i think i guess
quite naturally i'll always just make
opportunities happen and i'll get the
end result i want
conversations i find it really hard what
do you they look like
how do you stretch your day now today
like i'm sure because that's probably
what you've become better at if
if there's a structure so today oh
god today for example so i started um
specked out a few candidates this
morning started at eight o'clock
swept out a few candidates this morning
i had a bd call booked in with a client
actually this morning
at 8 30 which was the first client i've
had actually you'll be excited about
this hisham because i'm so excited
someone messaged me saying what do you
recruit in tech we'd like to work with
you
which was so exciting because it's like
yeah they've come to us which is awesome
and so i had a call this morning then
i yes i had some specking then a bd
meeting
had a catch up with a couple of members
of my team about bottlenecks and how
they're getting on
then i had an interview for someone at
transition partners actually which is
really exciting so hopefully hopefully
that goes well
and then i hosted this event and then
now i've come on your podcast so in
terms of bd time
it's been fairly limited but the
conversations i've had have been i've
been the right conversations
and i think that's probably a really big
tip
that i think's worked well for me
is like going with my gut if i you know
you're not going to be able to work with
everyone right not everyone's gonna like
ellie i know that right i'm not
everyone's cup of tea
but the ones that do like me will keep
buying from me and that's the important
thing so i think it's about building
relationships with the right people and
knowing when a lead is like
when it's going to be a bit of a dub
lead rather than pursuing it and hoping
and wasting
more energy your time and ultimately
it's going to end in disappointment
okay so no
okay so like any like
let me ask it this way so like because i
think it's interesting right because
some people may go right so
maybe initially first two hours of my
day always this
next hour always this blah blah blah
right so i guess what people are
interested in early is like
what daily must-dos have changed
that you think has impacted performance
increasing performance
i spend a lot of time on my network so i
spend a lot of time on social media
and i think a lot of people i think for
me it's one of those things i see it on
linkedin i see all these
all these eight marketing agencies that
say do this for linkedin to be
successful and do this to grow your own
direct business and blah blah blah and
you think bloody hell does that even
really happen to anyone and a couple of
months ago i felt exactly the same
but i do it because i love doing it and
it's helping me build a brand so by
investing in myself
for example just silly silly little
things
that um i am originally
from cornwall and i was watching a tv
program on sunday night simon reeve one
about why
cornwall is struggling to help youth
employment
but there's no careers for people in
cornwall right it's all holiday makers
and
once summer trade goes there's nothing
for people to do so i put a couple of
tweets out saying that i wanted to do
something to support
the cornish community and like can i get
involved in some
um tech events down there and do some
speaking to help inspire the next
generation
i ended up actually emailing my old
comprehensive school to ask if me and my
friends
yeah can come in and do um and do a talk
with them so that's getting organized at
the moment which is
gonna be good fun but i end up posting
about it on twitter blah blah blah next
thing i know
someone from startup in cornwall senior
and they want to have a chat with me
about recruitment
and it's okay there's stuff like that
now that you can if you
if you play it right and you do it
sincerely which 100
i wasn't doing that post with business
development i was doing it because i
care about people having the right
opportunity
and and the amount of knowledge that
i've gained as a recruiter and there's
so many things now that i think god i
wish i'd
known that when i was younger
particularly in tech like there's some
really cool stuff going on and there's
so much opportunity for people and they
just need to know about the
opportunities that are available to them
so it's my job to inform people of that
and help them with that
and i take that job pretty seriously
actually so um
i think it came from a sincere place but
opportunity came off the back
of it which is win-win so the daily
must-do is
has been really investing your network
building your brand okay yeah
let me ask you this and ellie you said
you're someone that was a you as a big
guy that you didn't you've always had
sort of you're on your growth in these
things
oh this year no no as in like so the
question is
like as um
a top builder a high-performing builder
what have you done yourself
to motivate yourself to keep pushing and
breaking records
i think my team will that now more than
ever so my team itself
makes me competitive which i love really
yeah do you know what i've never had a
team quite like my guys right now
right they'll probably be listening to
this and they are really really cool and
they're really bloody good
and i've been top top biller for years
at transition partners
sandra doesn't build directly so i mean
she's a great recruiter but
i wore that crown for a while loved it
this year it got ripped off me by my
girl sarah in germany
which i was stoked about like i'm so
happy
that my team are like really making
waves and
and that pushes me so much that
motivates i love that
so much like honestly me and sandra are
a bit competitive as well like
we're a great team like we'll do bd
together all the time like a little bit
like
work on people together and then
and that works really really well but my
team itself by knowing about god they're
doing this and they're on these
conversations they were on ten roles
yesterday i'm like bloody oh i better
get to do some business development
myself that's not doing me up
so yeah right now my team motivate me
and
the wider business yeah we've got some
really exciting things going on and
it it's brilliant to be a part of it
okay
so yes the okay that's interesting that
your team's end up being the motivation
so
right so before we finish this let's
talk a bit about
leadership and and maybe how you've um
had to sort of adapt your approach
during
um the difficult um period the last few
months and all that
but like really quickly so i um
i saw this advice come through from one
of the mentoring sessions and
recruitment mentors the other day and i
thought really good advice so when i
said that people
um people's aspirations and their
recruitment critics become a director
right so i'll ask this question and it'd
be interesting to see
if this was relatable or something you
did whatever but this this tip and
advice that came through was
how important it is if you really want
to get to that director level or head
over whatever the title is
that it's really important that you sit
down with the person above you the owner
of the business whoever it is above you
that can help you get there or
makes a decision or whatever how
important it is to sit down with that
person and actually map
out and understand and agree together
what you need to do to get there
right how many people actually sit down
with let's say sondra
if they're in the same position as you
and go right so if i
achieve this in the next 90 days will
you give me another apprentice if i
achieve this in the following 90 days
will you then give me let's have a
conversation about getting shareholders
in the business whatever it may be
right so like how what have you done or
how have you approached
getting those opportunities you clearly
recognized with your gut there's an
opportunity in this business to be more
than just
an employee you're number three and all
that right which is part of it
circumstances environment but you've
given yourself that opportunity to like
i guess
have you did you do any of that or like
how did you make sure that you was that
person that got opportunities to own
part of this business or get that
director
status i think
i made myself transition partners
quite quickly so i literally really
embedded myself in the business and put
my i was
the foundations of tp and i'm there i
might not have been known year one but
i'm there 100
so i've made myself kind of i guess
invaluable to the business
um i didn't sit down and go what do i
need to do what do i
i don't remember like having
conversations like that but
i naturally i guess you probably can't
do if you're from a bigger business
you're from a bigger agency you would
need to do that right it's quite easy to
get overlooked
um and i'm sure probably a lot of bigger
agencies well the next step for you
would be management but that's not
always the right step for everyone
i think you just need to make yourself
really invaluable in valuable you need
to be like
you need to be seen you need to become
that business and when you do start
working for a smaller consortium that is
definitely easier
the opportunities that we have
transition partners even hiring now she
was having a conversation with someone
yesterday
and the tech recruiter that we're
interviewing and i was saying to him
there's not many businesses where every
time you
kind of we hire someone we see it as a
bit of a new opportunity and although
we're not kind of sat back glaring as in
like we've done this and we've done that
before and
we've got this experience and we've had
this success and we're actually like
we're here to learn from one another and
and we open i guess people are welcome
with open arms and that they come in and
make a real difference
if you don't get that opportunity then
you can go somewhere else because
there's plenty of opportunity
plenty of companies over there who need
really skilled people who can add value
and
if people aren't investing you in your
recruitment then more for them
because it's so silly because i don't
know why you wouldn't you couldn't
i mean you could start your own business
tomorrow if you wanted but there should
be opportunities laid out there for you
because if you're successful then that
is the business
our business is people and if our people
progressing we're progressing so there's
no reason why we shouldn't be
supporting them and looking after them
to enable them to do the best job that
they can do
so did i sit there and do a full
business plan
no but did i barge my way in and give
her no choice but to make me a director
probably yeah
yeah no i think that's the advice like
it's what you said earlier it came
through quite natural to you treat it
like it was your own business
and you made yourself indispensable that
that's what you've done and when you do
that and truly do that
you're going to give yourself
opportunities right so i think that
that's that's the lesson there and
that's what how people should approach
it
particularly in modern environments i
was in an agency of that size and
you could you could definitely grab that
two hands if you really wanted it if you
really wanted
to become indispensable this company and
take those opportunities then
yeah it's it's exactly that um so
before i ask you the final five
questions then
um let's just talk about um
really quickly like elliot the leader
then like what what's been
what's been your biggest challenge with
leadership recently
as a whole you said obviously
communicating how you do things or
what works for you whatever sometimes to
the team but like in terms of one of
some of the common questions i get
from people is like as a manager how can
i
help recruiters that can't see the like
the end of the tunnel or can't
sort of um sometimes lack self-belief
but you know that they
they they have what it takes but
sometimes they can just sort of get
that lack of self-belief how do you help
people get over that how do you
um get the most out of your team all
these typical things always come through
from
managers and want to know how people
approach this so i guess what
what things have you found difficult in
leadership
i guess a couple of things like for me
probably one of my biggest strengths
is building confidence in people whether
it be my candidates about to
attend an interview my clients who are
about to i don't know
potentially apply for the next job
opportunity within their company or
or my staff and my team i think i'm
really good at helping people
push the boundaries and stretch
themselves in a great way and build
their confidence
and which has been really good but for
me management didn't come naturally
leadership didn't come naturally and
actually i didn't i didn't enjoy it for
a long time if i'm honest with you i
don't
i fell into it because i had to do it
because the business grew but
realistically if i worked for a bigger
company that i never would have i
wouldn't manage for a few more years and
i would have just carried on billing
and i probably would have made more
money if i had done that to be honest
so i think kidding yourself that
management is the only next step
is a silly thing to do and i definitely
if you're in that position now where
you're thinking actually i'm not really
enjoying it
then try and find another opportunity do
you really need to be doing that does
that mean
that you're successful by taking that
next step or not i think
um a lot of people think they need to
and they don't um
but now i really love it so it's
taken me a long time i i i managed
before in my old job i used 17
20 girls back in harvey knicks and i
hated it then
didn't like it when i went into it at
transition partners but i just had to do
it but
over the past trend yeah what's changed
um
i guess maybe me as a leader i've taken
i've this past 12 months i've really
chilled out a lot
um i'm quite highly strong individual i
move 100 miles an hour and my
expectations of people
were the same i truly don't like it
i treated everyone like they were me or
sandra and they're not
like everyone's individuals and they've
all got different strengths which is
thank god with all the same otherwise
our office would be bloody crazy
but and i think i got got to grips with
that about learning people's strengths
and weaknesses and giving people
time but also i kind of took a little
bit of pressure of myself because i'd
always just put so much pressure on
myself to bill and still make money and
build clients and stuff but
but now i do actually enjoy the success
like actually for me if i make a
placement yeah cool
good i've got someone a new job that's
great actually i
love it when my guys make placements
like i get so excited about them billing
and new
new terms i just go like yeah absolutely
nutty about it because it just gets me
so excited because i remember when it
was like my first client or
you know i mean like they're doing some
really great things um
we definitely got a really strong team
actually and i think for now
this year has been awful and uh it's
just been such a shitty year for
everyone and
and i've had a couple of like personal
things that have gone on that have
that have taken me knocked me back
really
and um i think that from a
leadership perspective i've been a lot
more vulnerable about that
whereas before i wouldn't have been like
i'm very open person
and and and i think that's i think
that's done really good
as a leader actually i love that so
advice for new billing managers then
or do you really want to be a manager
and that's and that's a fair question
like don't think that's the only step
like do you actually
want to become a manager or have you has
it being forced upon you like if i'm
someone that does
see myself as a leader or a billing
manager billingly the light and i'm on
that trajectory
what would your advice be to me what i
did for a long time actually that i
think
over hindsight now if i was to tell
myself what don't do
don't answer everyone's questions all
the time because they're going to keep
asking you questions forever
so what i try and do now is just
constantly ask them what do you think is
the best solution for that but they'll
come to you with bottlenecks all the
time it's going to happen and most of
the time they do know themselves but i
think by turning it round on them
by making them accountable for the
situation and coming up solving problems
then
it's going to help you so much long term
rather than constantly
needing support and needing help so i
think definitely push it around on other
people and ask for their ideas and then
what i'll do
usually is i'll come up with a solution
and then i'll just like sprinkle a bit
of glitter on it and just say why don't
we try this to do
like you know something a little bit
different than the credit like it hasn't
all come yeah no it's not come from me
at all i'm just i'm just helping you
is that that's a really good really
practical go to questions and so the
question was
what do you say what solutions do you
think we could have for this or
what yeah i turn it around straight on
them if they if they ask me a question
i'll just literally turn around and then
well what do you think would be the best
thing best course of action what should
we do today on this and yeah so just put
it straight back on them listen
and then if there's an opportunity to
sprinkle some glitter on it that may
give you
an opportunity to like do well then it's
they've
they've come up to that conclusion
themselves rather than you go and do
this
yeah because most of the time it's
something really obvious isn't it but
i even do it now sometimes i just want
someone to go yeah
you're doing the right thing like the
amount of times i'll be doing
an important email and i'll send it to
sandra or she'll send me an email to
check and we just want to
we want to do the best best job we can
and sometimes you just need someone a
bit of reassurance and that's what
management is most of the time
is giving someone an opportunity a
platform to do something amazing but
then reassuring them and supporting them
from the sidelines
okay that's that's what we should be
doing so got a final question because i
definitely wanted to ask
you this before i ask you the sort of
five quickfire questions
and like and because i see you guys do a
lot of this in the tech world like how
how do you think we can move the needle
on creating more female role models in
recruitment
it's hard for me because i work in a
business that's eighty percent female
so i uh yeah i don't really see this
being a problem
in my business but um if not in ours we
actually want more boys
but um i do a lot of initiatives within
women in tech
um and i think it's about exploring
opportunities and
i guess it's just using the same the
same principles and applying it to
recruitment
telling people about the opportunities
if i speak to young people and they
don't know what they want to do and i
think they've got the right
characteristics to make them a good
recruiter i will tell them
that they should give recruitment a go
because what six months eight months in
recruitment it could completely change
their life and it did mine
but the impact that it's had on
opportunities available to me
networking financially i would not have
had that opportunity
i mean i left school i can't even tell
you what gcses i've got
there is no way that i could have done
as well as i have in any other industry
so i like to shout about it
and tell people how cool it is and i'm
actually tonight this is exciting
my uh 18 year old cousin's ringing me up
because she's got an interview
for a job in recruitment downtown so i'm
like super excited
yeah i've actually told her to listen to
your podcast actually so basically the
advice is
tell more people about it like if you if
you're someone that thinks you know what
they could be great in recruitment like
tell more people about it like
yeah you don't always have to be a
certain type of person i've seen
different types of people different
personality traits be really successful
in recruitment
so there isn't like a one size fits all
for what makes a good recruiter so tell
people about the opportunities that are
wrong with recruitment it's all a bit
i mean like you say a lot of people said
to you about rector x and it's a little
bit cloaker dagger isn't it when you
first go into it you've got no idea what
it's all about but
i think by talking about it and um by
talking about all the amazing
opportunities and life-changing events
that recruitment can happen in the
confidence
i mean the confidence that recruitment
can give you i don't think there's many
other industries like it
i mean we've got some people in our
business and when they first started now
we've
just seen them blossom into completely
different people and it's
it's really cool to see so i think if
you can you if
you love recruitment and it's made an
impact in your life
and you think someone would be good at
it definitely tell them about how great
it is encourage people to get into it
it's an awesome industry
love that so i've got five questions for
you okay
oh god it's okay
first one is if you could change the
industry what would you improve
god there's so many things isn't there
recruitment that people don't like and
what would i prove
um more around unconscious bias
for me is a big thing from a recruited
perspective
i think recruiters do it i think hiring
managers do it i think recruiters do
when they're recruiting recruiters and
it just yeah i
don't like it so it needs to be more
education around it and we need to do a
better job of being
unconscious with anyone and everyone
interesting what
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you
i'm really not a reader listen to
podcasts
i like you you also have kind of helped
me honestly i'm not even joking
i've been like a day one fan everyone
who worked for tp they all listened to
your podcast because i
i i genuinely think that some of the
stories that i've that i've heard have
really helped
inspire me and like but you know when
you i mean sometimes recruitment's
bloody horrible
and i think by listening to other people
and being able to relate to that you
cannot that i mean that's why i love
doing my podcast now because people say
that how much it makes a difference to
them
and i think yeah by listening and some
of the stories that you've had have been
really impressive and they've certainly
helped me when i've been going through
like [ __ ] storm of a week do you know
what i mean
thank you
all right let me ask you so the next one
is um
if you could write a linkedin post that
could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant across the world
what do you want it to say
oh my god i meant to say something like
inspirational here or something that
like whatever whatever comes up for you
like if you could communicate to
every single recruiting professional out
there and they'd see it they'd read it
they'd listen to ellie what would you
want to say
oh my god
i think being original being true to
yourself is more important than anything
and i am definitely not on my linkedin
if anything i over share
but i think like being being true to
yourself as a recruiter and
have i think ethics business ethics is
so important and doing the right thing
is everything to me by my clients by my
candidates and um yeah be true to
yourself just because your manager wants
one thing if that's not you don't do it
don't you don't you treat yourself yeah
be true to yourself and who you are and
you'll be great at recruitment
next one what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
it would have been a holiday i love a
holiday yeah i got my yeah
oh do you know what i've had loads of
fuji ones i've even
been now where i'm like i've sent my mom
and dad on hold and i've sent my chat's
mum and dad on holiday and that's
actually nicer than well actually it's
not as nice to get away but it's really
nice to be able to do that
you know i mean i think that to me
i'd much rather go on holiday than buy
i'm not i'm not particularly flashy i'm
very yorkshire for someone who's moved
up north i'm very
awkward like i'm pretty tight so i'm
just always saying how tired i'm
actually love that
final one ellie final one is um
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
i wanna take tp to the next bloody level
like i already think
i love my business like we've got the
coolest people in there they're doing
some amazing things
we the sky is the limits like honestly
if we could get more people like we've
got there's no reason that we can't take
over the world with recruitment we've
got something very special bottled up
and um to be able to put that out in the
net into the community would be amazing
grow the business yeah i love what keep
doing what i do and love what i do like
that's really
important for me i'm happy i love
helping people and
and being able to do that you know i'd
love to keep doing that i'd love to do
more public speaking
keep the podcast going keep the events
all the fun stuff and let's just grow on
it and think of new ideas be creative
innovative within our field and
yeah enjoy what we're doing take it to
the next level why not
take over the world yeah america watch
out
you know we're coming love it and it's
been absolutely pleasure i think you've
been on a working journey and um
it's been awesome having you on the pod
thank you
thanks so much for having me i've loved
it